- [Kelly] Welcome to we live (indistinct).
So do you remember when
you first moved here?
- I do.
It was in, I think 2003.
I've been here for a long time,
and when I first moved out here,
I moved with two of my girlfriends.
Cause we were like, we don't
have any responsibilities.
We should try LA.
And one of them had been an intern at,
- (laughing) I love that plan
- It was a great plan,
and one of them had been an
intern at, in a set department
at SNL, and Chris Kattan,
they had become friends and he was like,
"you can stay in my pool house",
and the other two of us
didn't have anywhere to stay,
so we just like secretly
would go in and out
the back of his pool house.
That was like our housing
for the first three months.
And I don't think he knew, well, I mean,
he probably knows now.
- Oh my gosh
- [Kristen] But yeah.
That's where we stayed.
- So you just snuck up on his property.
I love that
- [Chris] I knew it
- I knew it this whole time.
- [Kelly] (laughing)
- [Kristen] (laughing)
- [Kelly] (clapping hands)
- (audience clapping)
- [Kelly] Chris Kattan everybody.
- [Kristen] - You.
- [Chris] You.
You.
- You, Kay Bell,
or whatever they call you.
- (laughing)
- [Chris] You owe me,
$322 and 27 cents.
- [Kristen] (Laughing)
- Could you tell me.
Could you tell me which
way to the Judge Judy set?
- Its over that way.
Okay.
I got my eye on you.
- [Kristen] (laughing)
- [Kelly] (laughing)
- (audience clapping)
- [Kristen] I love you.
- [Kelly] He is like (laughing).
He is like, What?